a family with no place to call its own
after being evicted from its apartment
earlier this year now with their County
Housing assistant program application
still pending they want to know when
help will come Victoria Saha looks into
the stories of those needing rental
assistance she joins us now live
Victoria Kirsten it's hard for any of us
to ever imagine being homeless for
Gwendolyn Clinton she never thought that
would be her reality and now she's
pleading for help as she waits on an
answer from Clark County
life will ever be the same for us life
for Gwendolyn Clayton and her husband
was simple before covet 19. I had a
full-time job
everything was going good Clayton is the
only provider for her family which led
her to apply for Clark County Care's
housing assistance program also known as
chaps but she was still evicted the
Constable was at my door February 3rd
I'll never forget it since the pandemic
started in 2020 Clark County issued more
than
375 million dollars to help with rental
assistance in January the guidelines
changed those facing eviction were
eligible to apply by January 23rd
Clayton applied in December that
application is still pending nobody
knows what to do with this situation
when you're already homeless but you
have a chat application in Clayton her
son and disabled husband no longer have
a permanent home laid our seat back down
as far as we can
put a little bit there let him have the
back seat my husband laid his seat back
and I maintained the front seat
and just lay it back a little bit so I
could just kind of be awake
can you imagine people that don't have a
guard for a family who barely had
anything left they even offered to share
their space with a stranger because he
just was cold
he was freezing his hands were blue it's
a harsh reminder of what some Clark
County residents are facing until their
chops application is approved according
to the County's website they say they
added 250 new employees to help with the
program but the overwhelming number of
applicants has created a backlog I feel
like it failed us
the clintons are able to stay with some
family right now but it won't be for
much longer I reached out to the county
asking what options do residents have
and I'm still waiting on their response
Kirsten thank you Victoria the Clark
County's website also States if you have
a chaps application pending you are not
allowed to be evicted now Victoria is
still trying to find answers as to why
Clayton was evicted during this time